in Lebanon supporters of two Shia
movements have been fighting with
anti-government protesters for the
second night running Hezbollah and Amal
supporters Amal oppose protesters
demands rather for a complete overhaul
of Lebanon's Parrott sharing system
reports are divided on a sectarian basis
it's some of the worst violence since
protests against the ruling elite began
last month well seems like these are
putting Lebanon's military and security
forces in an increasingly difficult
position they've gone to great lengths
to protect anti-government protesters
for more than a month now confronting
the powerful iran-backed Hezbollah could
ruin the neutral stance the military
seeks to maintain and split its ranks
the Army is one of the few state
institutions that enjoy white public
support it's seen as a unifying force in
a deeply divided country well earlier my
colleague Foley Party boss booked to
Rami Khouri
he's a journalism professor at the
American University of Beirut
she asked him what message Hezbollah and
its allies are trying to send by putting
their supporters out onto the streets so
one theory is that there these are this
is a show of force just before the
negotiations begin to create a new
government to maintain a certain role
for them in the new government that's
created another theory is that no this
is a not linked to any kind of political
resolution this is the Hezbollah and m/l
and some other people allied with them
saying we're fed up with this kind of
citizen protest and the issues that is
causing and we're going to send these
people back home as has happened in the
past were a little bit of rough handling
by the the young men of Hezbollah and
Amal and others has sent protesters back
home so we'll see which way it goes yeah
and the Lebanese army meanwhile finds
itself in the middle of this can it stay
neutral if the situation were to
degenerate if you know things were to
get worse is there risk that the
Lebanese army could be facing off with
Hezbollah as powerful forces no there's
no risk of a army Hezbollah faced off
that's never going to happen the risk is
that the army would get pulled into the
tensions on the street and some of the
violence and then perhaps the army would
would implode from within it would
collapse and some Shia members some
Christian members some Sunni members
some Druze members would all leave the
army and go from their own militia this
is what happened during the Civil War
when the army collapsed but I don't
think that's going to happen